One-third of the population of China can't
speak the country's official language.
4% of the sand on Normandy beaches is made
up of tiny metal particles from the D-Day
landings.
In most countries, the most popular programme
on TV is the weather forecast.
In 1983, 50 corporations controlled most of
the American media, including magazines, books,
music, news feeds, newspapers, movies, radio
and television.
By 1992 that number had dropped by half.
By 2000, six corporations had ownership of
most media, and today just five dominate the
industry.
Prunes were served as aphrodisiacs in Elizabethan
brothels.
In Georgian, mama means 'father' and deda
means 'mother'.
Most of the Italian extra virgin olive oil
sold in stores is not genuine.
Nearly 70% of cheaper olive oil is not from
actual olives, but cut with cheaper seed oil
to lower the price and much of the product
doesn't even come from Italy.
The most common street name in the United
States is Second Street.
Main Street is second.
Birds living in cities start the dawn chorus
five hours earlier than in the countryside.
Frog juice, made by putting frogs in a blender,
is an aphrodisiac in Peru.
In 2000, it cost $3 billion to sequence a
human genome.
By 2014, the cost had fallen to under $1,000.
During the First World War, German and Russian
troops agreed a ceasefire and joined forces
to fend off attacks by wolves.
William Morton, the father of anaesthesia,
first experimented on himself but kept falling
asleep before he could describe the results.
Bill Murray was once pulled over by the Swedish
police for driving a golf cart under the influence
of alcohol.
20 million barrels of whisky are maturing
in warehouses in Scotland.
Swedish programmer Ludvig Strigeus, the main
developer of Spotify, is also the programmer
that made µTorrent.